so Syria is a domain-specific language
aimed at low latency in high-throughput
bit string processing and with
particular application to the
implementation of the physical layer of
wireless protocols which is the layer
that receives samples from a radio and
does the processing of these samples to
transfer them into strains of bits and
bytes that go to higher layers of
networks taxes so there is a programming
language for wireless system programming
and to break it down to explain what it
means if you think of wireless this
means your signal so getting transmitted
as electromagnetic waves to be here and
you need to convert that into your data
packets which carry your webpages or
videos whatever and but to do that you
need to love number crunching so
basically what happens is you digitize
these waves it come to the air and you
get a lot of numbers out of them and you
need to compare these numbers very fast
and typically that's done in hardware
like your Wi-Fi chip who do that or your
cell or chip will do that but that
limits your experimentation with it if
you want to design new generation of
technologies or you want to upgrade to
newer version that's not possible in
harder so the challenge was if I have to
write something myself some part of this
number crunching process and then I have
to put it in this big program I'm
working on it's very difficult to give
that piece of code someone else in my
team or in the community that reuse it
because it's so optimized that filling
it all together with the rest of it's
very difficult so what we are doing with
Syria is we provide a programming
language that is specially designed for
these kind of tasks which allow you to
write these programs doing this number
crunching in a high-level way that you
can easily understand and
exchange with your colleagues and so on
reuse by the same time runs very fast as
it really as it is required with these
protocols our starting point going away
when we design Syria is that it's
extremely challenging to get so
pipelines that operate in the rates that
the wireless protocols require and it's
very hard to maintain and reuse software
components that other parts of these
pipelines so Syria addresses exactly
these challenges makes it easy to write
components for shortly software
pipelines that are easy to maintain and
at the same time perform the main
benefits of Syria is first of all it
capture some of the specific concerns in
physical layer pipelines for example the
distinction between how the data flows
through a pipeline and how the pipeline
reconfigures itself during the
computation so 0 expresses this in a
high-level way and at the same time
Syria allows you to write software
components for this pipeline and in a
high-level fashion but optimize them
automatically for the particular
placement of the software component in a
processing pipeline you can quick link
program and develop code and the code
portability that you can share your code
and build the community efforts around
it which we've seen in many areas allow
much faster development and much bigger
project to be built and also portability
and building large-scale experimental
platforms which have not been built so
far because of the complexity of
actually implementing
you